and our next guest reveals which rival
the Trump team is most concerned about
joining us now is Rudy Giuliani attorney
for President Trump and former
presidential candidate himself Rudy
great to see you nice to see you
so is the president shaking in his boots
shaking in his I don't know capture to
toe shoes over comments not he's not
shaking at all about Kamala Harris or
any of them I mean the president
realizes is there's gonna be a candidate
we don't know who it is and they're
gonna have to make all these crazy
charges but I think he's pretty
comfortable and I am certainly with the
fact that they've all gone so far to the
left
I mean Kamala Harris is in favor of open
borders I don't know what kind of
prosecutor she is if she's in favor of
open borders if you're in favor of open
borders you must be in favor of open
doors in your house let everybody in
let's not find out who they are or
identify themselves I mean she's in
favor of late term late term abortion
late term meaning the day before the
baby is born we can go on and on and on
high taxes she does a little better job
than some of them like a Warren and and
Bernie of disguising herself is not
quite as left-wing but when you examine
her positions she's very very left-wing
and I think she's a flavor of the month
because Jo couldn't defend himself it
was kind of pathetic I mean she
eviscerated him and I thought it wasn't
with very much and I think that I think
we got a very very big signal from
Michelle that was definitely calculated
you saw that I mean you pointed it out
beautifully but Michelle is a very smart
woman whatever else she is yeah I mean
Rudy she could have said I'm not taking
sides here on the presidential contest
but we know Jill Biden very well Joe and
Jill were really close to us we served
them for eight years not a racist bone
in his body
do you think it's a isn't that easy to
say and she she went out of her I think
she went out of her way both of them not
to say that I mean but you can't you
don't hear peep out of Barack Obama
unless it's some sideswipe at Trump
without really mentioning it by name but
I found that to be also I kind of found
that to be graceless on the part of the
at a bare minimum a Biden is entitled to
he's not a racist they know and also
he's not look I have a lot of issues
with Biden including what appears to be
a lot of corruption I mean China and
Ukraine you know hundreds of million of
millions one place billions other place
while he's negotiating for America his
son is pulling pulling down millions of
dollars and Joe was taking him there on
Air Force two come on you know if that
were one of us we'd be indicted by now
but I believe the Democrats aren't
touching that yet because they're trying
to take him out on his lack of
competence and and Joe Rudi they seem
very and surprisingly unprepared they
should have been prepared for incoming
from someone they know is close with the
oboe
I mean look let's face it Joe's never
been a good candidate and I know he'll
get really insulted but he's not that
bright and the president says that it
happens to be true everybody always says
oh he's funny he's Uncle Joe fact is
he's not the brightest bulb in the he's
a backslapper type and he's a back and
he's not that smart
Rudy Jill spoke out tonight and she's
got the rest of these people are smart
she's smart yeah Michelle's very wicked
smart and they also realize he's not up
to it and they want to win and I think
they feel that Joe is gonna self implode
at some point they want out well Jill
Biden spoke out tonight and they were
clearly stunned and ill-prepared for
this attack let's watch biggest surprise
for you so far
the biggest surprise I think was the
debate I think you know I think probably
Kamala was a little bit of a surprise I
think that's the biggest surprise so far
she again how do you how are you not
prepared for that that's almost a
disqualifying in and of itself of course
it is I mean if you're not prepared for
camel are I are you prepared for are you
prefer for Kim Young on and puddin and
people in China Joe isn't prepared now
that's the sad truth about a minute Rudy
we got a lot of other topics I want to
get to because I think we
we destroyed that topic I want to get to
what Attorney General Barr said about
Muller's upcoming testimony next week
watch I was disappointed to see him
subpoenaed because I don't think that
serves an important purpose dragging Bob
Miller up if he in fact is going to
stick to the report it seems to me the
only reason for doing that is to create
some kind of public spectacle and if Bob
decides that he doesn't want to be
subject to that then the Department of
Justice would certainly back him what do
you make of those comments well I think
that you know the Attorney General
realizes this has gone way beyond what
normally happens and way beyond the
bounds of ethics and discussing the
facts about somebody about whom you're
not going to bring charges I mean a four
hundred and Plus page report a ten
minute sort of suggestive press
conference and now we're going to repeat
it all with you know this kind of
glorified testimony I think the Attorney
General is very concerned about from a
political point of view I almost I
almost like it because I believe that
the Republicans have a lot of good
questions to ask Mahler that he's going
to have a very hard time answering and I
think the net the net of this is going
to be that people are gonna have more
questions about Muller after it's over
than before they go in but you know what
I can see why the Attorney General if I
was in his position I'd be very
concerned about how this is really doing
something terribly unethical that
prosecutors are taught you never should
do you'd never talk about a case when
you decline prosecution ever ever ever
yeah we're getting into this topic later
on the show but I did want to get your
take and thoughts on what's happening
with Jeffrey Epstein you know he pled
not guilty today on charges of sex
trafficking minors I mean breathtakingly
hideous allegations did you know him and
did you have any interactions with him
ever I don't believe so I don't I don't
remember ever meeting him his face looks
a little familiar but it may be because
I've seen him on television I can't
imagine that I know him and his real
close friend was Bill Clinton I mean
he's the one who traveled on planes with
him went all over with him I'm not
saying that Bill Clinton was involved in
any way but he's the one he was really
close to
I can't imagine I ever had much to do it
I don't recall ever have anything to do
with them yeah and it looks like they're
clearly after this Alex Acosta labor
secretary for the president with that
plea deal any thoughts on that tonight
well my my view is somebody charged with
the things he's charged with is you
throw the maximum penalty at him I don't
know what he decided his US attorney I
don't want to second-guess that but you
know my knee-jerk reaction to it is the
guy should be in jail for a very long
period of time given what I know
publicly and then I have to put in the
caveat you know everybody's presumed
innocent one final thought Rudy a
question Nancy Pelosi spoke out today on
the census citizenship question and made
just an outrageous swipe more than a
swipe at the president watch this is
about keeping you know make America you
know this hat make America white again
they want to make sure that people
certain people are counted it's really
disgraceful and it's not what our
founders had in mind who are we what is
America I don't know what's wrong with
her the question is Nancy whether you're
a citizen we have white citizens black
citizens we have Hispanic citizens check
ID
it's whether you're a citizen Manton but
why did she say it Rudy going back to my
angle this is by any means necessary to
take out this president they want to
divide this country they want to turn
white against black Hispanic against
black white against I mean it is a
cynical well they take every every
single thing that is done whether it
relates to anything like that or not
they will interpret that way it's like a
talking point they just repeat there is
nothing racial about asking someone
whether they're a citizen it's like you
know seeking identification before you
vote that's how is it maybe she knows it
and she's saying it and you have to
produce identification to get on an
airplane yeah she's smart she's doing
this for a reason
they're worried about the Trump gaining
even a five percentage points among
african-american voters because a great
economic record he's had with with
Americans create criminal justice reform
I think they're panicked about that want
to do the country on racial lines I
think it's disgusting the players
everybody is doing better in this
economy everybody the president when he
ran you know in 16 said take a chance on
me you can't do any worse yeah and you
know they're doing better than they've
ever done all of us and particularly
minorities we got to go really great
great to secure